on le sait la période liées à la
pandémie est particulièrement difficile
pour les étudiants qui en france essaye
de s'accrocher mais pour elvis 17 ans la
situation est d'autant plus difficile
car il n'a pas de papiers parfaitement
intégré dans la société française ce
jeune homme arrivé du kosovo il ya cinq
ans est aujourd'hui un élève brillant et
sociable un garçon aimé par son
entourage
sauf que voilà l'administration
française ne l'entend pas de cette
oreille
le jeune homme est en effet menacée
d'expulsion malgré plusieurs mouvements
de soutien les choses n'avancent pas
elle vise maj rami ce soir sur notre
plateau pour lancer un appel
[Musique]
elvis est avec nous mercialys merci papa
merci pour l'invitation vers 16h alors
il ya eu énormément mobilisation tout
concernant tu arrives et du kosovo qui
ava moore il ya maintenant cinq ans oui
c'est vrai ça va ya cinq ans et je suis
arrivé j'ai essayé de m'intégrer comme
cheveux tu sais que ton témoignage est
très très attendu ce soir
merci vous car plein de gens qui
t'attendait sur les réseaux sociaux qui
voulait te te connaître un peu mieux
pour quelles raisons vous avez quitté le
kosovo tabac à montredon alors on est
arrivé là il ya cinq ans est on arrivé
car ma mère rbd sérieux problèmes de
santé
d'accord et mon père l'a emmené dans
tous les hôpitaux de du kosovo mais
étant les hôpitaux aussi des pays qui
entourent du kosovo et mais on a on n'a
jamais trouvé de solution
alors vous êtes venu en france
effectivement vous avez démarré
vous avez démarré ta scolarité en
intégrant un collègue est de dijon c'est
ça c'est cela et ta maman elle a pu se
faire soigner en france alors dans le
dernier hôpital du kosovo un médecin
nous a conseillé les hôpitaux français
d'accord et ensuite
suite à cette ce conseil ma mère était
encore réticente par rapport à devoir
quitter quitté le kosovo
ensuite il a appelé le frère et son
frère et sa soeur qui sont présents en
france également d'accord qui disait en
france
effectivement et ils ont expliqué que je
pourrais avoir un avenir merveille en
france et que la france est un pays où
ne travaille dur et vous repensez alors
tu ne parlais pas du tout français
effectivement c'est incroyable est ce
que tu vas faire là-bas tu parles mieux
que moi c'est vraiment joli
est ce que ton intégration a été
difficile en france où est ce que tu
t'es tout de suite intégré
je me suis tout de suite intégré car je
voyais déjà un bel avenir devant moi
d'accord le voyait déjà faire des
longues études airs compense
effectivement les concessions et les
sacrifices que mes parents ont fait pour
moi est vraiment je me voyais déjà faire
des longues études je sais de faire un
expert-comptable plus tard ah oui perrin
box puis suit est vraiment ce qui suit
je suis très bien à twitter comment nos
bottes mais si tu années aqmi suite avec
ces mots on va on va écouter en classe
de première on parle de toi comme étant
un élève brillant et parfaitement
intégrés on va entamer la dernière
partie touche pas à mon pote et juste
après je vous faire écouter sonore c'est
parti dernière par km2
écoutez ce qui est des scouts qui des
toits ce qui se dit toi sur france bleu
regarde écoute plutôt tu es un stress
permanent puisque c'est le risque
d'envoi en centre de rétention et
d'expulsion du territoire alors que vous
avez le vice est un élève qui est
brillant qui a fait cinq années de
scolarité en france qui a les
félicitations au lycée depuis le début
de la seconde là il est en milieu de
première donc il doit pouvoir finir
jusque son bac et nous on pense même que
il doit pouvoir choisir après son bac 2
poursuit ses études en france
alors avec ta 20 en maths etc si moi
j'ai réussi à obtenir de moyenne en
maths
moi j'arrive en musique non mais 20 en
donc tu veux devenir expert-comptable
aujourd'hui tout se complique pour toi
et ta famille puisque en novembre
dernier
ta maman a déposé une demande de titre
de séjour qu'elle se voit refuser
elle reçoit ce qu'on appelle une
occulter s est une obligation de quitter
le territoire français
comment tu as vécu cette annonce alors
quand j'ai appris ça c'était le
désespoir pour moi et mes parents on a
été vraiment très triste et envoyer tous
ces années d'efforts et tous ces années
travail ou où j'espère et je voyais déjà
1 à venir vers moi j'ai construit une
nouvelle vie et j'ai oublié l'ancien
nature est vraiment gsm intégré au
maximum j'ai fait beaucoup d'amis qui
m'ont soutenu et d'ailleurs je le
remercie et franchement j'ai vu tous ces
années tombé à l'eau mais quand mes amis
se sont mobilisés pour moi ça m'a
redonné sourire ça m'a fait chaud c'est
quoi tous tes amis de d'ulysse et en
première s
oui c'est ça ces premiers renoncer en
maintenant il ya les spécialités oui je
suis en première générale j'ai prié
spécialité maths sos et littérature
anglaise j'adore moi aussi je suis un
fou de littérature on se rejoint mon
chéri tu as et aujourd'hui tu vis avec
la peur d'être expulsé à tout moment
effectivement c'est ce qui se dit là
quelqu'un on est la situation
actuellement la situation est
actuellement c'est que je peux me faire
attraper
- être envoyées et vraiment je vis pas
serainement jeu même quand je suis chez
moi je suis pas tranquille
enfin ça ça me stresse je vis avec la
peur est vraiment c'est extrêmement
difficile à vivre qu'on est quand on
entend des pas qui monte des escaliers
cesser les voisins mais non pense que
c'est la police du coup ça nous coupe la
respiration porter et vraiment c'est si
c'est très dur à vivre c'est vraiment
quelle est la raison pour laquelle votre
dossier a été refusé il l'a refusée
parce qu'il ya eu un refus d'un autre
dossier en fait c'est ça qui nous
empêche une autre demande d'arrêter même
pas enregistrées elle a été considérée
comme dilatoire alors que mes éléments
de scolarité ça apporte un élément
nouveau et je rempli les conditions pour
enfin je remplis les ça fait cinq ans
que je suis ici ça fait pratiquement
cinq ans aussi je que je suis à l'école
donc je jeu remplit bien les conditions
l'époque et ce qui pourrait se passer et
ce qui serait un drame c'est que tes
parents tu sers parts et toi tu puisse
rester c'est ça oui c'est ça ce serait
vraiment vraiment très très très dur
pour moi parce que ma force ma force de
base quand je suis arrivé ici quand
j'étais dans les pires moments
tout ça c'était mes parents en fait un
tueur et ils ont fait pincer sacrifices
pour moi je veux qu'ils soient
récompensés en restant ici parce qu'ils
aiment la france
et j'aime aussi la france et il
travaille t par an non ils n'ont pas le
droit du coup ils ont même pas le droit
de prendre un logement comme les autres
du coup on doit faire en deux ans dans
des studios alors il ya le préfet de ta
région fabien sudry qui s'est exprimé
sur la situation la semaine dernière
qu'a dit ici double responsabilité ma
première responsabilité de faire
respecter les lois du pays mon rôle est
de les faire appliquer
sinon il n'y a plus de liberté possible
mais en même temps je ne suis pas
insensible aux enjeux d'humanité il ya
donc cette recherche de compromis
je n'ai pas encore pris de décision donc
fabien sudry préfet de la côte d'or
c'était le 13 janvier 2021 ce qui vous a
contacté personnellement le préfet n'ont
toujours pas d'accord qu'est ce que tu
voudrais dire aujourd'hui aux
téléspectateurs et aux gens qui nous
regardent peut-être aux gens du
gouvernement au préfet peut-être si nous
regardent qu'est ce que tu aimerais lui
dire d'abord j'aimerais remercier toutes
les personnes qui m'ont aidé et qui se
sont
battus pour moi et qu'il y en a beaucoup
qui vont continuer à se battre pour moi
jusqu'à que j'obtiens ce que je suis
venu pour et que je reste avec eux et
que même après avoir fini mes études je
renvoie la pareille à la france en
trouvant un travail ici et reste avec
mes parents et faire un bon futur et 6
et franchement je demande la tension la
tension sincère sur mon dossier au
préfet mais est ce que tu es ce que tu
as bien sûr conscience elvis le problème
qui va se poser c'est que force est bon
s'ils le font pour toi il va y avoir
énormément de demandes derrière et c'est
ce qui expliquait un petit peu le préfet
et c'est vrai que c'est c'est une
situation compliquée on espère vraiment
que ça va s'arranger pourtant on a
essayé de faire le maximum encore une
fois pour essayer de télé et c'est vrai
que c'est un problème compliqué jean
pierre je sais que tu connais pas le
dossier voiture est compliqué mais quand
on vous à dire j'aime la france par le
serveur au bout de cinq ans en première
il a commencé sa première année de bac
vert
on a envie que pour acheter de la
marchandise est restée avec moi comme ça
c'est génial franchement tu un sourire
incroyable merci merci tu vas pouvoir
rester merci de tes parents aussi parce
que c'est vrai que ce serait un
déchirement petit parents eux c'est pas
parce que toi tu restes qui je pense est
pour toi ça va ça va que j'ai peur que
ça casse la dynamique et que ce soit
très très compliqué pour toi que tu
restais avec ce patient ta famille en
tout cas on va suivre ton dossier le
vice on va essayer de tout faire pour
t'aider mais je vais essayer de savoir
ce qu'on peut faire avec certaines
autorités voir si éventuellement ils
peuvent suivre ton dossier et on va voir
ce qu'on peut faire également avec le
préfet en tout cas merci ton témoignage
bien sûr qui a fait énormément réagir et
merci à toi d'être venu nous voir sauf
les airs vers 6 et merci de m'avoir
invité
[Applaudissements]